[Music]
on this Thursday night a boost to the
battlefield Canada's contribution of
heavy weapons to Ukraine these four
tanks are combat ready as Russia fires a
new deadly barrage of missiles an
estimate of the far-reaching and fatal
consequences of covid-19 misinformation
it makes me so sad that so many people
could have been saved The Big Dig
a major snowstorm that's created a mess
for millions of Canadians and the
asteroid on course to whip past the
Earth why it's not the end of the world
global national with Donna Friesen good
evening and thanks for joining us hours
after it was confirmed that Western
allies including Canada are sending
tanks to Ukraine Russia fired back
launching a volley of missile and drone
strikes killing at least 11 people
across Ukraine and targeting energy
infrastructure
Canada's defense minister confirmed
today four of Canada's leopard two tanks
will be sent along with ammunition and
spare parts and Canadian troops are
being deployed to train Ukrainian
soldiers it's all part of a coordinated
effort to boost Ukraine's tactical
advantage on the battlefield we'll get
to more on Canada's contribution in just
a moment but first Crystal commencing on
Russia's deadly response
lives turned upside down
this is such a tragedy for me I'm
telling you I'm left without anything
deadly Country-Wide missile strikes
possible retribution for Ukraine's
securing battle tanks from Ally Nations
Russian newspapers featured stories
about the tanks with a pro Kremlin
Slants
state run TV mocking the donated
equipment calling the American units
battered and the German leopard's
toothless cats on the streets of Moscow
people parroted the views
Russia needs scrap metal that's all let
them send tanks
since our country started all of this we
need to kick them in the teeth
Canada is the latest country to join the
battle tank donor list on Wednesday
Germany confirmed it would send 14
leopards followed by the United States
pledging 31 Abrams Poland the UK and
France are also a part of the group that
Kremlin accuses of a blatant provocation
while at the same time disparaging the
value of the machines it doesn't matter
whether it's the Challenger the Abrams
or the leopard you know they have
overmatch on Russian capabilities in
terms of their Firepower and certainty
protection
while visiting his troops Germany's
defense minister says their tanks could
be on the ground in Ukraine by Spring
that would allow for a push to reclaim
territory when the weather is more
favorable
but ukrainians must first get through
the winter
Crystal commencing Global News London
Canada's defense minister has confirmed
what we reported yesterday that Canada
will send four german-made leopard two
tanks to Ukraine Mercedes Stevenson is
with me from Ottawa Mercedes four is
something but is it all we can offer it
is all we can offer according to the
defense sources I've spoken to without
risking potentially gutting the Canadian
Army's capabilities we have so few tanks
that this was pretty much all they
thought they could offer and still be
able to defend Canada the tanks we're
sending are actually the tanks the
Canadian Armed Forces train on we don't
deploy them but they're still considered
to be superior to what Russia is
operating in Ukraine they'll be
delivered by Canadian C-17 planes which
can lift very heavy things like tanks
and that's expected to happen in coming
weeks there's still questions Donna
about where spare parts might come from
for these tanks but it's still a good
start according to retired Major General
Dennis Thompson he's a former NATO Task
Force Commander this is what he had to
say the logistics of this is going to be
uh
probably even more difficult than the
training challenge because of the mix
and match of equipment that Ukraine has
inherited but as people like to say it's
a good problem to have better to have
the equipment and the logistics headache
rather than not have it at all
Mercedes what about the possibility of
retaliation for sending tanks well that
is a very real possibility and it's
actually something that one Canadian
intelligence agency is warning about
tonight the communication security
establishment which is responsible
things for things like Canada cyber
security is warning defense and critical
infrastructure providers to brace and
prepare for potential Russian attacks
the Russians have threatened this and
we've seen it happen to allies and now
that Canada too is offering tanks they
say that we need to be vigilant that it
could happen here too in coming days
Mercedes Stevenson in Ottawa thank you
it's almost February and if you're tired
of winter that's the good news spring is
inching closer the bad news another
snowstorm has wall up Southern Ontario
and Quebec and is blustering its way
through Atlantic Canada and yesterday in
Kingston Ontario this happened
lightning and thunder in a snowstorm
it's called thunder snow a number of
people captured images of the rare
weather phenomenon meteorologist Anthony
Farnell will go into more detail on that
in a moment but first Mike droulet on
the storm's impact
montrealers have an expectation when it
comes to Winter it's either cold snowing
or a mix of the two what they don't
expect is having to wait until the end
of January to see it
and now with 30 centimeters of fresh
snow the city is scrambling to salt and
clear 10 000 kilometers of roads and
sidewalks we will need more than five
days to complete the operation the storm
had the expected impact on air travel
with many flights canceled out of
Toronto and Montreal leaving passengers
temporarily stranded our flight arrived
really late last night so we actually
had to run to try and catch our other
flight and get them to open the door for
us and managed to get on that plane but
then plane got canceled so
it's been it's been a day
actually it's been a winter unlike any
other in recent memory
with many ski hills in Ontario and
Quebec that have relied almost solely on
artificial snow ecstatic to finally see
the real stuff
in Toronto cars were sliding all over
the icy roads which some saw oddly
enough as a challenge were you for fun
or uh yeah we just wanted to see how it
was around here
and in Ottawa where the canal has yet to
freeze digging out didn't seem like a
chore well I'm actually kind of happy it
finally is acting like winter and Ottawa
but alas not everybody is smiling
Atlantic Canada got its fair share of
snow but with rain already falling
thoughts of skiing have been replaced
with concerns about flooding microlyte
Global News Toronto
Global News chief meteorologist Anthony
Farnell is tracking this storm and the
thunder snow for us Anthony
well this large storm that we've been
tracking for days is lifting to the
north quickly that's a good thing
towards Labrador and Newfoundland so the
worst of the rain the snow those
damaging winds will impact these areas
next it's improving weather for Halifax
and the rest of the maritimes after a
day of wind and power outages and 50
millimeters of rain this is the second
big storm to hit that area this week
back to the West around the great lakes
in particular in Kingston a rather
unique phenomenon occurred in the
heaviest snow yesterday it was hours of
lightning strikes what we call thunder
snow it is a phenomenon not too
different than a summer thunderstorm
where you need updrafts and lift and
also friction but still it is a rare
occurrence and it happened quite a few
times in Kingston yesterday back to you
thunder snow is real Anthony thanks
millions of people in the U.S are also
also under weather alerts a storm system
brought tornadoes to the South and snow
in the Midwest and Northeast
tornado in Texas sent this family
running from their RV to seek shelter in
a ditch car crashes littered highways
hundreds of thousands of people were
left without power there have been at
least 158 reports of tornadoes this
month alone making it the most active
January on record in the U.S other parts
of the U.S are digging out and preparing
for more snow through Monday and
countries in East Asia are struggling
with days of heavy snow and freezing
temperatures in Japan at least four
deaths are being linked to Winter
conditions there record lows were also
recorded across South Korea and the
capital Seoul temperatures stayed below
minus 15 degrees for two straight days
and in China earlier this week the
country's northernmost City recorded its
coldest temperature ever minus 53
degrees Celsius
well we know misinformation and
conspiracy theories are spreading faster
than ever before largely online but
quantifying the damage they do is not
easy now a group of academics has
attempted to add up the impact of
misinformation about covid-19 in Canada
the Council of Canadian academies
estimates misinformation contributed to
the vaccine hesitancy of more than 2
million Canadians during a nine-month
period in 2021 it estimates that
hesitancy led to at least 2 800 deaths
along with an estimated 300 million
dollars in medical costs it says
misinformation also led to deep
divisions within Society even within
families divisions that continue today
and as Heather York's West explains
there is no vaccine for that
I want to cry
it makes me so sad
um that so many people could have been
saved for Trudy Ballard the findings of
a new study by the Council of Canadian
academies feels so personal because they
are in October 2021 Trudy Ballard lost
her dad he died of covet 19. there's so
much misinformation being put out there
and unfortunately he believed a lot of
that Ballard believes misinformation
prevented her dad from getting the covid
vaccine researchers say he was far from
alone using a mathematical model a panel
of experts have tried to measure the
cost of covid misinformation in both
dollars and lives what would things have
been like had all those people who died
kobit was a hoax gotten vaccinated as
soon as they were eligible had that
happened the models suggest that within
a nine month period of 2021 there would
have been 198 000 fewer covid-19 cases
13 000 fewer people in hospital and 3
500 fewer patients in ICU it wasn't just
anti-vaccine and conspiracy theory in
the 5G chip theory that was that was
ripping through our hospital it was the
lack in of faith in healthcare
professionals and expertise that was
killing us and it's that distrust and
the anger that followed that's perhaps
more difficult to quantify and even
harder to fix we were the victims of
death threats um to this day I have
certain distant family members who
accuse me daily of being a mass murderer
from vaccination so what's the solution
the CCA report says there's a lot of
work to be done from holding social
media companies more accountable to
ensuring accurate information is
communicated more effectively of course
nothing can be done to give Trudy time
back with her dad she just hopes
something can be learned from his death
Heather York's West Global News Calgary
Toronto police will be increasing their
presence on buses and streetcars to try
to reduce the number of violent attacks
this week two people were taken to the
hospital with serious injuries after
being stabbed and bus drivers were
swarmed by a group of teenage boys
these deployments will focus on reducing
victimization our officers will be on in
and around the transit system across the
city
throughout the day and late into the
evening each and every day
Toronto's police chief says about 80
additional officers will be stationed
across the transit system and the
Transit Commission is also adding more
special constables to shifts as well as
improving camera surveillance other
cities across Canada have had similar
spikes in random violence prompting
calls for a national task force to try
to come up with a potential solution
the head of VIA Rail has admitted that
company could have done more to help
stranded passengers during last month's
winter storm that caused major service
disruptions across Ontario and Quebec
and he says via is hired an outside
consulting firm to review what went
wrong I think a lot of us need to take
stock of what happened
and address the elements that are under
our control to make sure that if ever
one of these events happens again that
the impacts on our passengers is
minimized senior via Executives appeared
before a House of Commons committee
today to answer questions about the
delays in some cases passengers were
stranded on trains for more than 20
hours via also set a CP Rail derailment
near Toronto which was out of its
control contributed to the problems via
added that climate change is making
Transportation Systems more vulnerable
outrage from grieving families coming
off their demands Boeing be held
accountable for two deadly plane crashes
plus record breaker what this woman says
is the key to enjoying the Journey of
life
foreign
Boeing was in court in Texas today along
with family members of those killed in
two crashes of the 737 Max Jets Boeing
told the court it was not guilty of
concealing information about flight
control systems but flaws in those
systems were found to have led to the
accidents still Boeing avoided a trial
by agreeing to pay a 2.5 billion dollar
settlement this hearing marks the first
time Boeing has been forced to answer
the fraud charge in a public court after
the judge hearing the case ruled those
killed were Crime Victims and should
have been involved in settlement
negotiations
we live in a pain in distressed unstable
ground and yet the murderer walking free
going home to their loved ones
I did not only lost my daughter I lost
my past
my today my future my tomorrow and same
with all these people
nearly 350 people were killed in those
crashes in Indonesia and Ethiopia in
2018 and 2019 a new Boeing flight
control system was found partly to blame
grounding thousands of Max Jets
worldwide for 20 months
attention Home Depot Shoppers ahead what
you need to know if the store emails you
receipts
many Canadians are more aware than ever
about data privacy and data breaches
these days and when a Canadian man was
deleting his Facebook account he was
shocked to find the site's parent
company meta had a record of most of the
in-store purchases he'd made at Home
Depot he made a formal complaint to the
Privacy commissioner who found his data
and that of thousands of other customers
was being shared without their consent
turia isri explains
would you like your receipt emailed it's
a question Canadians are routinely asked
at the checkout
customers at Home Depot thought their
emails were only being shared with the
retailer but they were unknowingly
handing them over to someone else as
well when they were buying at the
counter they had no reason to suspect
that this information would be shared
personal data was shared with meta the
parent company of Facebook and Instagram
without customers consent to track
purchases and send targeted ads details
that were revealed during an
investigation by privacy commissioner
Philippe Dufresne what we were
investigating in this case was the
Privacy practice of Home Depot and
ultimately we found that Home Depot did
not sufficiently protect its customers
information the emails Home Depot shared
were encoded so they could not be read
by Facebook employees but dufren found
meta employed an automated process that
allowed it to match email addresses
attached to Facebook accounts unlocking
a trove of data the Privacy commissioner
launched his investigation after
receiving a complaint it's not clear how
many Home Depot customers are affected
but the commissioner says it's likely a
high number since the company secretly
shared information for four years this
went on between 2018 and 2022 Home Depot
says it did not notify customers of its
information sharing agreement due to the
risk of what it called consent fatigue
before collecting personal information
and businesses should really be
informing their customers on on how they
plan on using that information
um and if they're going to be sharing
the third parties despite the discovery
the hardware chain is not facing any
fines
well it certainly may be that there are
other companies that are engaged in some
of the same kinds of practices the
retail world has become more digital but
lawyers say legislation is lagging
behind when you see this kind of misuse
I think of people's personal information
people would expect real penalties and
Canadian Privacy Law at least as it's
currently structure just doesn't allow
for that Parliament is working on
strengthening consumer protections an
upgrade privacy experts believe is badly
needed tariya isri Global News
Ottawa
just swinging by next what you need to
know about an asteroid coming
exceedingly close to Earth
[Music]
maybe you've heard the saying age only
matters if you're a cheese well the
woman who is now the oldest person in
the world has some tips on how she stays
feeling young Maria bran yes Moreira is
115 born in San Francisco she survived
two World Wars the Spanish Civil War and
two pandemics she credits her longevity
to Tranquility connection with family
and friends contact with nature
emotional stability lots of positivity
and staying away from toxic people
and don't get hit by an asteroid tonight
an asteroid the size of a truck brushed
past the Earth just 3 600 kilometers
away one of the closest approaches ever
recorded and it's not like we've known
about it for a long time it was first
detected just last week by this man an
amateur astronomer in an observatory in
Crimea he also found the first
Interstellar comet in our solar system
keeping an eye on these things is
important Eric Sorensen explains why
if the solar system were a barber shop
this would be a close shave an asteroid
the size of a delivery truck is zooming
beneath communication satellites and
over the southern tip of South America
skimming just 3 600 kilometers above the
surface of the Earth streaking at 540
kilometers per minute from the Solar
System's vast ocean of asteroids 2023 bu
was only discovered last Saturday the
asteroid 2023 bu is as close an asteroid
pass to the Earth as I can ever remember
we can't see all of the asteroids that
are coming at us sometimes they are
surprising professional and amateur
astronomers are spotting new asteroids
all the time thousands have been
discovered in the last 25 years most
like 2023 bu are small and pose no
threat but the risk is not science
fiction NASA's planetary defense office
is on constant asteroid watch including
2023 BU as it passes by right now last
Falls Dart mission anticipates a future
threat it crashed a spacecraft into a
tiny asteroid to change its orbit and it
worked as far as we can tell our first
planetary defense test was a success
asteroid tracking and vigilance are
essential Earth's gravity will change bu
2023's orbit around the sun which means
all number of asteroid orbits will
change around other planets and some
could suddenly head our way astronomers
around the world as I said professionals
and amateurs are scanning the skies
because the situation can change
significantly along with the risks from
asteroids are potential rewards
including mineral wealth the seven year
long osiris-rex mission to asteroid
bennu is on its way back to Earth with
asteroid samples they'll arrive home
just eight months from now demonstrating
what's possible asteroids represent a
growth industry as scientists look for
new asteroids and try to avert the ones
as Hollywood imagines it that might come
looking for us
good luck to us all Eric Sorensen Global
News Toronto
global national for this Thursday I'm
Donna Friesen tonight's your Canada is
this foggy scene in Calgary thanks for
watching hope to see you here again
tomorrow bye-bye
[Music]